Let's go next to our caller from the three
one, two area code.
Who's calling today from three one two.
Oh, I know a name.
That's you.
Yeah.
Who's this?
Oh, yeah, this is Chris.
I'm from Chicago.
I was just watching your video about like
that, you know, like Elizabeth Warren's, uh,
gun safety plan.
I think a lot of it would work and um, I'm
not really knocking it too much, but, uh,
I don't know, like a, what do you think about
like some people on the left who don't really,
uh, I don't know.
Like a lot of people say they don't feel safe
about stuff like that, you know,
they don't feel safe with what, what do you
mean?
Well, like a, there's some left that say like,
well, you know, like, uh, I think that like,
I don't know how to describe this.
They say that like it would only affect a
certain group of people.
Like there's some things that I've read on
this, right?
Like it was like a sort of have like a background
checks on all guns and online purchases, you
know, that's reasonable.
Um, you know, like, and you have like an 18
plus restriction on the cells and like, you
know, you get rid of that boyfriend loophole.
Like I'm reading this like that cause I took
a screen cap of it.
Um,
but do you mean, let me see if I understand
Chris, if, are you saying some people say
that only people who would bide by the law
will be effected by different laws so that
in reality, like criminals are just going
to illegally get guns either way.
So who, what does it matter?
Are you talking about that?
Oh No, no, no, no.
I'm just saying like that you'll still like,
uh, cause like I do agree with a lot of them,
right?
Like, cause you know, I'm from Illinois and
like, um, it's illegal for people from Indiana
or certain parts of Illinois to uh, you know,
make cells like in certain areas.
Right.
Cause like that's where like most of the guns
come from.
Yeah.
Um, I'm just not sure like how beneficial
it would be to like, or if it's like if a
lot of people would even be on track with
that.
And I just wanted your thoughts on that.
Oh, well yeah.
So I mean you, you are right about one thing,
which is that this has been studied in a lot
of different countries and within states just
one change.
Like for example, making background checks,
completely universal for all transactions
as an example.
That alone is not going to have a significant
impact.
But the way that these things work is when
you put together like a package of changes,
that's when you get a more significant impact
and it does decrease the availability of guns
to be illegally transacted as well.
That's often, so I think you're right in that
just one of these changes often feels like
it wouldn't do that much because it actually
would not.
But there's a lot of studies from many different
countries ranging from, you know, Australia
is all over the place.
Um, that tell us that when, uh, a package
of gun safety laws is passed together, um,
that that does have a significant impact and
it reduces homicides.
Definitely.
Like, and I'm like, I didn't say that to like,
be like I was disagreeing with you.
I just wanted your thoughts about it.
Yeah.
You know, I think it'd be totally work to
give it a try.
You know, like, oh, Chicago is like a fun
place, you know.
But yeah, the one thing that I found really
interesting was that one thing that you were
talking about with the, uh, the stores that
sell these firearms, right, are not the firearms
that, what does it like ammunition in the
firearm, like delayed, like kind of cut in
like they closed on their throats a little
bit.
Like when you know, they make yourselves and
I think you could see like a decreased hopefully.
Absolutely.
Chris from Chicago.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
And we will obviously continue covering the
gun issue.
Thank you.
Take care of Ya.
Uh, that does it for calls today.
Sorry to everybody.
I did not get to, but I did my best.
Uh, we will take calls again and thanks to
everybody who called it